hello everyone and welcome to today's
session two webinar simple steps to
publication quality western blots i am
jennifer woods of labrutz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
caleb sharrow product manager protein
detection at thermo fisher scientific
caleb you may now begin your
presentation
hello
thank you for joining uh this is part
two of a three-part webinar series for
simple steps to publication quality
western blots uh my name is caleb cerro
i will be covering part two of this
series
i'm a program manager in protein
detection at thermo fisher scientific
so let's dive in
so this really comes from
um a joint workshop that was held in the
nih uh with nature publishing group and
science uh on the reproducibility crisis
in science and uh western blotting was
one area uh where concerns were raised
over the reproducibility and the quality
of western blotting data
so
what should we do about this was kind of
the the topic of
the
the meeting so
the publications revise their
instructions on
how to submit non-quantitative and
quantitative western buying data
to reflect some of the meetings
conclusions
so what we'd like to do
is help you understand how to get
publication quality results out of your
western blot and i will focus on two
topics in particular today as part of
this session
the first one is improving background
with experimental design and we'll cover
both ways ways to do that from a chemin
luminescent detection standpoint and
also a fluorescent detection standpoint
and then the second thing i'll cover
today is improving detection when you
have low abundant protein meaning your
target protein is is very low abundant
or it's scarce
so some tips and tricks on how to
generate publication quality data when
you're in that scenario
but let's start with improving
background with experimental design
now the first thing that probably comes
to mind when we're talking about
improving background is selecting the
right blocking buffer
but we're also going to discuss how wash
buffers can impact
your background as well
from a fluorescent standpoint
there are actually a couple other
considerations that are important to pay
attention to one is your sample buffer
uh also blocking buffers should be
optimized a little bit differently for
fluorescence and then your membranes as
well and we'll cover all three of those
so let's first start off with
chemiluminescent western blotting and
how to improve your background uh over
on the left side of the screen you can
see kind of a list of tips to keep in
mind so i'm just going to walk through
those and then we'll shift to the data
that is shown on the right side of the
screen the first thing is
if you're using a pbs system whether
that's pbs in your blocking buffer or in
your wash buffer
it can interfere with alkaline
phosphatase conjugated secondary
antibodies
so it's important to to use tbs when
using ap conjugated secondary antibodies
you should avoid milk based blockers for
biotin systems if you're using an avid
and biotin complex that's because a lot
of times there's endogenous biotin in
milk blockers
you may want to avoid casein based
blockers when you're looking for
phosphoproteins or trying to detect
phosphoproteins
short blocking times can result in high
background so you want to make sure
you're blocking a sufficient amount of
time
azide may block hrp activity so using
azide free reagents can help
and then strong blockers or over
blocking can mask antibody antigen
interactions which will limit your
target signal detection and i want to
really emphasize this point because i
think it's one
that not a lot of folks pay as much
attention to as they should
when looking on the right side of the
screen when we look at that data
you can see that uh
the five percent non-fat milk blocking
buffer that's all the way on the right
side actually shows the least amount of
bands
now the background is pretty comparable
between the three blocking buffers but
you can see that your sensitivity is
reduced when using that five percent
non-fat milk because there's so much
variety
of proteins and things that are in that
milk that can actually cover up
uh antibody binding sites on your target
protein
which will impact your sensitivity and
your ability to detect your target
protein as you can see in this data now
if we move to the left you can see
pierce clear milk blocking buffer
performs a little bit better than five
percent nonfat milk because we actually
go in and remove some of that extraneous
stuff that we don't need that may be
covering up the target protein and then
if you move left again and you look at
the starting block blocking buffer you
really see the best sensitivity
of the three blockers because we can see
more bands across that block
for both iraq 1 and bcl xl
so
it's important to optimize your blockers
not only for reducing background but
enhancing your target signal
we have several different blocking
buffers available and we kind of have
some specific use cases for each one
there's not one blocker that is great
for 100 of situations uh so we we do
have uh
a larger portfolio to be able to
accommodate different scenarios
now if you want a blocking buffer that
covers most scenarios but maybe not all
scenarios but most scenarios your best
bet is thermoscientific starting block
blocking buffer
this is a great blocker for when you're
optimizing a new western blot system it
performs with a wide range of antibodies
and antibody combinations it's
compatible with strep damage systems and
it blocks in less than 15 minutes
we also offer it in pbs tbs pbst and
tbst so a lot of options for this one
moving to the right we recommend using a
casein blocker we offer ours as thermal
scientific blocker casein
when you have high background or limited
target signal with homemade milk buffers
it's a high performance replacement for
homemade milk blocking buffers uh we
reduce kind of some of that variability
and variety that's present in your your
five percent nonfat milk blockers
in it so it could be a more repeatable
reproducible blocker for your experiment
we recommend moving to the right again
we recommend blocker bsa for when you're
targeting phosphoproteins
and we recommend thermoscientific
blocker fl
for fluorescent applications
and we'll talk a little bit more about
that when we get into fluorescence
now i mentioned
that blockers are not the only aspect
that you want to address when you're
trying to
reduce background and maximize your
target signal you also want to pay
attention to your wash buffer now adding
tween 20 detergent to wash buffers
generally will help you reduce the
background in your western blacks but
you do kind of have to pay attention to
how much you're adding to your wash
buffer there is kind of a goldilocks
zone you don't want to be you don't have
too much you don't want to have too
little too much will result in washing
away proteins and antibodies too little
may result in high background
we generally recommend 0.05 percent to
0.5 percent
to
perform the best sodium chloride can
also be added to reduce background
and one thing we've noticed uh when
washing blots is that multiple short
washes are better than
fewer washes
that go on for longer so the example we
use here is six five-minute washes is
going to be better than one 30-minute
wash
all right so now let's shift the
conversation from chemiluminescence to
fluorescence one key consideration is
your sample buffer if you have sample
walkers with blue or pink dyes it can
fluoresce
uh when you go to image your blot and if
it fluoresces too much
it may overpower your target signal so
you may be unable to detect your target
only because you're using the wrong
sample buffer so to avoid this
you can use a fluorescence friendly
sample buffer without bromophenol blue
uh we offer one called the in vitrogen
fluorescent compatible sample buffer and
this is a non-reducing sample buffer
it's ready to use uh you can add a
reducing agent such as gtt so it is
reducing agent compatible
um and it's it's a lane marker die so
it'll be a visible marker of your die
front that you can monitor throughout
your gel electrophoresis
also it's convenient it's stable at room
temperature so you can store it right
there at the bench or wherever you do
your electrophoresis
another key consideration for
fluorescence is
choosing a fluorescence compatible
transfer membrane
and when we look at this data on the
right hand side of the screen we show
nitrocellulose at the top
which has some background
it's not terrible but it's certainly
there so it could it could hurt your
signal to noise ratio if you don't have
a lot of signal from your target protein
if you look down at the bottom and just
normal pvdf
there's a lot of background a lot of
fluorescence background particularly at
488 nanometers so you want to be really
careful not to use pvdf membranes when
running fluorescent
western blots particularly if your your
target
secondary antibody
has a 404 at 488
we suggest using a low fluorescence pvdf
you can see it has the
least amount of fluorescence background
across the 48 and 680 and it's pretty
comparable to nitrocellulose at 800.
for those customers or or participants
that are on the call that are currently
using in vitrogen iblot 2 or in nitrogen
power blotter pre-assembled stacks we
add the low fluorescence pvdf to those
membranes so
no need to change it that's what you're
currently using otherwise we offer the
stacks as well as the low fluorescence
pvdf if you're looking to optimize a
fluorescence
western blind method
next i wanted to touch again on that
blocker fl that we we showed a little
bit earlier
it's really important to get a high
performing uh fluorescence compatible
blocking buffer um so that you don't you
know have too too high a background and
you're also getting uh plenty of target
signal so one thing that we we do call
it here is you should avoid blocking
buffers with detergents and you should
really try specially formulated blockers
that are intended for fluorescence
detection when you look over on the
right side of the screen we compare
blocker fl with five percent milk and
you can see there's a big difference in
sensitivity because that milk is really
covering up a lot of those uh antibody
binding sites on the target protein so
you're seeing much less signal than you
do with blocker fl and we see that
across wet blots as well as dry blocks
so just to summarize on improving your
background uh using the right reagents
and designing your experiment can be a
huge help in getting you to that
publication quality western black data
the first thing you want to make sure to
do is choose the right blocking buffer
there is not a one size fits all blocker
for all systems
the second thing is consider adding
tween 20 detergent to your wash buffer
and use multiple short washes
finally choose a fluorescence friendly
reagent when you're performing
fluorescence detection also a
fluorescence friendly membrane
can make all the difference in
generating that publication quality
result
so
we'll now shift gears
and now we're going to talk about
improving detection
of low abundance proteins
so before i move past this slide i just
want to comment on what we mean when
we're talking about low abundance
proteins
there are several different scenarios
that you can find yourself in where
you're working with very little protein
one one scenario might be that your cell
model just doesn't express this protein
in great quantities so you have very low
expression of your protein
so you may need
special considerations to be able to
detect that protein
another scenario might be that you're
working with a protein that's very hard
to extract whether it be a membrane
protein or a nuclear protein maybe
the
cellular expression is high but just
getting that protein out of the cell is
very difficult and so you're left with a
very small protein sample
another scenario might be you're working
with very precious samples whether that
be like patient samples biopsy or a
very slow growing cellular model
if you're unable to get lots of sample
quickly you may need to
treat it
in such a way that you are getting as
much information out of as little sample
as possible
so all of these scenarios are
are
an example of having low abundance
proteins and needing to optimize your
western body
experiment so that you can get not only
the most information out of that
experiment but you can obtain public
publication quality results so let's
dive into it
the first thing you want to do is select
the right gel chemistry now we recommend
a biz tris gel chemistry for low
abundance proteins as well as post
modified small and medium proteins
because it has a neutral ph formulation
this is going to minimize the amount of
protein modification or protein
degradation
so you're really going to maximize uh
your your target protein
without degradation the more degradation
you have
the less intact protein you have and if
you're already starting from the space
where you have very little protein that
can make all the difference
so moving to the right side of the
screen here you can see we we show our
bolt gel which is a biz tris chemistry
and you can see we we see very little
degradation degradation would be
indicated by minor bands below that that
top major band and when we look at bio
rad's tris glycine gel we do see a lot
of evidence for degradation there we see
a lot of minor bands coming in
underneath
the major band
so if you're starting from a sample with
very
low abundant protein we want to make
sure we have as
little degradation as possible in
bistrous gel chemistries is one way to
ensure that
also some other benefits of the biz
truth chemistry is
to deliver sharp straight bands with
higher band volumes and also you get
better resolution they can be up to ten
percent longer which increases your
dynamic range and allows you to get
better resolution
for more protein bands in your gel
tris glycine chemistry can certainly be
used for high abundance or broad range
molecular weight targets but when we're
talking about low abundant proteins we
recommend the bistrous gel chemistry
also i want to comment on a couple of
our other chemistries
we have trif acetate gels for high
molecular weight proteins and tricine
gels for low molecular weight proteins
if you attended part one uh jordan
thompson touched on this in a little bit
more detail but i just wanted to to
remind you that when we're talking about
low abundance proteins
you may only have one or two westerns to
be able to get top quality results and
so if you are looking at a high
molecular protein we recommend the tris
acid hl it's going to give you your best
chances of getting publication quality
results on your first try in the tricene
gel for the low molecular weight
uh one other scenario i commented on at
the beginning of this section was you
know you may have a sample that's very
precious very hard to come by maybe very
expensive
so one way to get all that you can out
of that sample is to dilute it out so
that you can run several
westerns or several experiments on that
single
sample
now if you dilute it out
you may need to load more volume into
your gel to be able to detect that
protein so in that scenario
you may consider our wedgewell gel
format which allows for larger volume
loads
of dilute samples without any spillover
so if you look at the data on the on the
left side here we are showing our
wedgewell tris glycine gel
um with alternating wells where we we
loaded and then left blank loaded then
left blank and we we have the load
amounts up there on top we loaded 20 30
40 50 and 60 microliters and you you see
virtually no spillover into the the
adjacent lanes
now if you look uh right to the right of
that we have a bio-rad 10 well gel
uh and we did perform the exact same
experiment and in this one you can see
by the red arrows you do see some
substantial spillover into those lanes
which can really impact your results
particularly if you're not leaving those
lanes open and you're really trying to
run several lanes on a gel as you should
be able to
so we recommend using our wedge weld gel
format when you need to load uh higher
volumes
or if you just want an easier pipetting
experience
so now we've talked about optimizing gl
chemistry in gel format now i want to
kind of shift the conversation to ecl
substrates so when using ecl substrates
particularly when you have a low
abundant protein
you may run into some common problems
that are listed here on your screen you
may have weak or no signal you may have
poor signal to noise ratio maybe you
have a lot of signal but your background
is so high that you can't distinguish it
you can't distinguish your target from
your background
and also
if you do have those precious samples
and you don't
uh you don't get a signal or you get
very poor signal to noise ratio then you
basically waste that sample
and so one way that we can decrease the
amount of sample that's wasted is to use
a higher sensitivity ecl substrate
so we recommend uh two
main ecl substrates uh
one is super signal west pico plus so
that's on the left side uh in this table
west pico plus is a fantastic substrate
for routine western blots i would call
this our everyday western blotting
substrate
it has really good high sensitivity
compared to other ecl substrates on the
market
and also it's very robust it has a long
signal duration it it's
it's compatible with a wide variety of
western blotting scenarios
however
when we are talking about very low
abundant proteins or very precious
samples i would recommend using super
signal west ato ultimate sensitivity
substrate which is shown on the right
side of this table
super signal west atl can detect
target protein levels as low as low
femtogram to high atogram
which is
as sensitive as it gets
when you have a very low abundant or
very precious sample i would recommend
using this high sensitivity substrate
every time
so let's kind of let's kind of touch on
each
um substrate and talk a little bit more
about
how it compares to other substrates on
the market and when to use them
so we'll start with super signal west
pico plus
as mentioned we have exceptional
robustness for this one
it has a very wide dynamic range
it's compatible
with
most um recommended antibody
antibody ranges it has excellent
sensitivity compared to
uh other competitors on the market and
it has a long signal duration of up to
24 hours so
uh if you need to image several
different plots
but you're applying the ecl substrate
all at the same time you're going to get
a very consistent robust signal from
this substrate over a long period of
time
now how do we compare to some of the
other options on the market you can see
at the top we compare super signal west
pico plus to ge healthcare ecl and you
can see not only do we have an advantage
in sensitivity but also duration by
after four hours that ge healthcare ecl
substrate has basically
you know run out you don't get any
signal from it at that point whereas
super signal west pico plus is still
showing
a signal that's very similar to the
initial signal
next we compared ourselves to bio-red
clarity and we still see that that
improvement that advantage in
sensitivity
and signal so very high performing
substrate for most uh western blots
now shifting to super signal west atto i
already mentioned that it is the highest
sensitivity substrate um delivering over
three times more sensitivity than
conventional substrates
so when thinking okay you're getting a
lot more signal what's happening to the
background
well we also looked at signal to noise
and i've got a slide on this as well
and it actually has performs really well
in terms of signal to noise ratio
particularly against competitors
also this is going to preserve your
precious sample
and i i'll show a little bit more on
this too you don't need to load as much
sample or you can load those those
highly dilute samples
because you'll still get a signal
because it is such a sensitive high
performing substrate
so this gets to the signal to noise
ratio that i was talking about earlier
we compared super signal west ato third
clarity max ge amersham ecl select and
milliport immobile on western and what
we found is uh you can see in the graph
on the left
you can see super signal was ato is
showing the highest amount of intensity
across the four competitors
so how does it perform in in terms of
signal to noise well when we look at
that it's also the highest performing
substrate you can see to the to the
graph on the right uh super signal west
ato had the highest
signal to noise ratio uh
for every
my state load amount but if we look at
0.625
it's at about 2.1 compared to biorad's
1.3
signal to noise ratio so a very nice
improvement there
the other advantage of super signal west
ato is that you can preserve your
precious sample and we really wanted to
highlight this
because we know how precious uh you know
samples can be particularly when you
have low abundance proteins so we
compared super signal west ato to bio
red clarity and millipore of mobile on
and you can see we we tried to
match up the intensity levels so
if you look at the bar all the way to
the left
on the bar graph
on your screen you can see super single
west ato that red bar matches up pretty
close to bio-red clarity
so we tried to match those two signal
intensities
but now take a look at the lysate load
notice that super signal west ato to get
that level of signal intensity only
required
1.25 micrograms whereas biowrap clarity
required 20 micrograms
essentially load 1 16 of the amount of
protein
and get the same signal as the
competitor
and you can see to the left side of your
screen the bands represented in that
chart
so excellent way to preserve precious
sample or
to make sure you're getting signal from
low abundance protein so that you can
get publication quality results on the
first time
now
i have to comment on optimizing your
antibody dilutions i'm sure you're aware
antibody concentration is extremely
important when it comes to detecting
low abundant proteins however
a higher antibody concentration does not
always mean better results particularly
when working with with low abundance
targets
also too much secondary antibody can
quickly saturate your signal
when using super signal west ato
especially when trying it out for the
first time i would recommend actually
diluting your antibodies more
uh we've seen a lot of times if you use
the same concentration of antibody that
you're used to
super signal west ato is so powerful
that it will actually
blow out your blood it'll provide too
much signal so
you should dilute your antibodies uh
more when using ato and that's going to
save you money because we know how
expensive primary antibodies can be
right
so also another added benefit of the
high sensitivity of super signal west
ato
now shifting from chemiluminescence to
fluorescence
one thing we want to mention here is you
want to test a number of fluorescently
labeled secondary antibodies
even if they have the same fluorescent
tag a lot of different secondary
antibodies may have different binding
efficiencies so finding that right
secondary antibody that gives you the
right signal
it is able to detect that low about a
protein is really important so we
recommend testing
several different secondary antibodies
another thing i want to mention is our
super signal western blot enhancer so
this is a two-part system that includes
a membrane treatment to reduce
background and also a primary antibody
diluent to promote
uh antibody antigen binding so it's kind
of a it's a two pronged strategy to
get better signal to noise ratio first
we we decrease the background and then
we increase the signal uh by
by treating the membrane and then
promoting that antibody antigen
interaction and you can see it performs
quite well if you look at this basically
the same western blot one with the
enhancer one without
you get substantially better sensitivity
uh when looking at the iraq one protein
without the enhancer you can detect up
just about up to 1.25 micrograms but
when you add the enhancer you can
actually detect about 10 fold more
down to
0.156 micrograms
and you see the same thing reflected
with the bcl xl
so it's just another way if you have a
very low amount of protein to make sure
that you're increasing
your target signal and optimizing that
signal to noise ratio
when when looking at low abundant
proteins uh and generating publication
quality results
we recommend moving to a digital imager
now if you're still on the x-ray film
you're not the only one there's still a
lot of people that use film
but there are several benefits to making
the transition to digital imaging
sorry digital imaging
uh there's greater signal sensitivity
linearity and dynamic range
with the digital imagers you get
accurate and reliable quantitation uh
from the algorithms
you get digital storage of data this one
is huge for a lot of people they don't
have to store their film any longer
they can store it digitally
the auto exposure algorithms can
eliminate a lot of guesswork in
determining optimal exposure time so you
kind of you automate exposure time which
is very nice
it's eco-friendly you don't have all
those developer chemicals and
maintenance costs and there's no dark
room required not only is does that
eliminate um
space and the cost of using that space
but you don't have to work in the dark
either
introducing the eyebrite imaging system
family right so when you're looking at a
digital imager we are going to recommend
to go with the eyebrite
imager family uh and we call these smart
imagers we use smart as
um
an acronym so you have s is for simple
and intuitive we have a 12.1 inch
touchscreen that walks you through the
workflow
m is for multi-detection
chemiluminescence
5-channel fluorescence you can combine
your chemiluminescence in fluorescence
and then you have nucleic acid gel and
protein gel imaging modes so a lot of
different detection modes a is for
automation you have automatic exposure
zoom focus sample alignment and image
analysis with with optimized settings
for each imaging mode
r is for resolution we have a 9.1
megapixel camera uh to be able to get
the the most resolution out of your
western blot
images
and then of course technology is the
most advanced imager available in design
and capability
so
when looking at the eyebrite in
particular here we're looking at the
ibright cl 1500 imaging system
and we compare it to x-ray you can
really see an improvement in sensitivity
uh by looking at this data that we show
here so we we we're looking at plate
data um and we're exposing at 10 30 60
120 and 300 seconds
now we can see down to one two three
four five maybe six
wells um on that 10 second exposure with
the eyebrite compared to only three on
the x-ray film
so you really get a lot better
sensitivity with a digital imager
particularly with an eyebrite imager and
when you're looking at low abundant
proteins that can make all the
difference
these graphs really kind of just take
the previous slide and put it in
graphical form
but what this does is it highlights not
the sensitivity but the dynamic range
that you
get out of that eyebrite
even the x-ray film for the wells that
it detected you can see the the dynamic
range is
relatively very small compared to the
large dynamic range of the eyebrite
imager this is going to allow you to get
better sensitivity but you're also going
to be able to distinguish
expression amounts better
if you have one cell
that maybe you treated with some drug
and you're trying to see how much
protein is being expressed compared to a
control
you may not be able to see a difference
with film but you can pick up on that
difference from the eyebright imager
because it has a wider dynamic range and
you can more easily distinguish between
expression levels
in that point
is really driven home on this next slide
where you can get better signal
linearity you can see down here um
if you look where it says where we have
the letter d there
um
that's x-ray film and you can see it
saturates out that that linear signal
hits a plateau once you hit that plateau
you cannot distinguish between different
uh
expression levels or lysate loads
because you're getting the same signal
between the two different expression
levels if you have a linear
signal
that can that is made possible by that
wide dynamic range
then you can really get not only can you
distinguish between your expression
levels you can even quantitate your
western blot results
okay so i'm just going to
wrap up with kind of a summary on what
we just talked about in terms of
detecting low abundance proteins so the
first thing is to choose an appropriate
gel chemistry for your protein of
interest we recommend the biz tris gel
chemistry because it has less protein
degradation
you can load more sample using wedgewell
format gels
use a more sensitive chemiluminescent
detection reagent we suggest using super
signal west ato
test numerous fluorescent secondary
antibodies when when performing
fluorescence
consider a signal enhancer uh to boost
the signal and limit the amount of
background and really optimize that
signal to noise ratio and then utilize
digital imaging for improved signal
sensitivity and getting that wide
dynamic range
and that's all i have for part two of
our webinar today i really appreciate
your attention
um
and
i look forward to answering questions
before we get there
i do want to mention that we do have a
part three of this webinar that will be
presented by kelly feather hennigan
on october 14th at 9 00 a.m pacific time
12 p.m eastern time
5 p.m gmt and 3 a.m aet
finally
don't forget to check out our new
updated handbooks these are your go-to
guides for gel electrophoresis and
western blotting
basically what these are is they're a
comprehensive easy to use guide that
covers every procedural step from sample
preparation all the way to imaging and
data analysis and you can find other
educational resources and links
including how-to videos webinars and
selection to tools on our website at
thermofisher.com
western handbook you can also use the qr
code that is at the bottom of your
screen to navigate there
okay now i'm ready to take some
questions
thank you caleb for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you would like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
so should five percent milk also be
avoided as a blocking buffer for
fluorescence detection
jennifer sorry i was
working on getting unmuted can you
repeat the question
certainly
should five percent milk also be avoided
as a blocking buffer for fluorescence
detection
so
the data that we showed today um as part
of this presentation showed that while
five percent milk can work in in a
fluorescence application
we recommend our blocker fl because
we've seen that you can actually get
better sensitivity and better signal to
noise ratio
all right thank you caleb the next
question here
i use the start blocking buffer to block
my membrane can i reuse it if i can how
many times can i use it how long will it
be good and do you recommend to dilute
antibodies using the start blocking
buffer or use 5 bsa
so you can to answer the second part of
that question first you can certainly
use
starting block blocking buffer to dilute
your primary antibody
i would not recommend storing your
primary antibody in starting block
i think you can store your primary
antibody either
in
in the buffer that it came in or five
percent bsa
with regard to
reusing starting block blocking buffer
i would not recommend it
when you when you reuse a blocking
buffer
you're changing the formulation a little
bit because a lot of that protein is
binding to the membrane
and so you're losing a little bit of
of protein in your blocking buffer what
that can do is it can impact your
reproducibility because you're not using
the exact same blocking buffer
on your next experiment that you used on
the previous experiment so i would
recommend using fresh blocking buffer
each time you block your block
instead of reusing it
thank you again caleb our next question
here
for fluorescence you make the antibiotic
do you make the antibodies in the
blocker fl buffer 2
uh yeah so
similar to the previous question you can
certainly dilute your primary antibodies
in the blocking buffer
but again i would not recommend storing
your primary antibodies in the blocker
sl blocking buffer
all right great thank you again
our next question
in choosing the blocking buffer what
would be the difference between the tbs
or pbs based blocking buffer will it
make a difference if i switch between
the two
and what should be considered in picking
the blocking solution
one of the
the biggest considerations when choosing
tbs versus pbs is what enzyme you're
using for detection
so if you're using an hrp conjugated
secondary antibody
compared to an alkaline phosphatase
conjugated secondary antibody the choice
becomes very important
pbs because it's a phosphate buffered
saline will interfere with an alkaline
phosphatase enzyme and so pbs should be
avoided
when when using an alkaline phosphatase
enzyme
if you're using an hrp conjugated enzyme
in most cases
um
either buffer should should be able to
work for your system
unless you
unless primary amines
impact your your system i i think that's
relatively uncommon
uh to have to accommodate
the primary amine that's present in your
tris buffer
and so if you're kind of going with a
normal very common western bottom setup
and you're using an hrp conjugated
secondary antibody then you should be
able to use either tbs or pbs
all right thank you caleb our next
question what type of blocking buffer
would you recommend for a goat antibody
we tried milk and bfa at different
concentrations and different blocking
times and got high background and low
signal
so i would recommend our starting block
blocking buffer for this application it
does perform well with with goat
secondary antibodies
it sounds like this this is uh one of
those situations where you may have a
delicate or a
a
a secondary antibody that
doesn't like to play well with other
reagents
so i would recommend using our starting
block blocking buffer
but there may be some additional
optimization that you'll have to do
all right thank you caleb our next
question here if a routine ecl substrate
is used first and no bands are seen can
i use the high sensitivity substrates
directly after without stripping and
re-probing
yes
you do not need to strip and read probe
to use a higher sensitivity ecl
substrate you should be able to
maybe do a quick wash a quick rinse on
your blot and then add the
higher sensitivity ecl substrate
thank you caleb
okay next question here why do you
recommend using higher antibody
dilutions when using high sensitivity
substrates
i just want to make a quick
clarification on this question when
we're talking about higher antibody
dilutions
we're talking about lower antibody
concentration
so
right so that means that you're diluting
your antibody more which means you have
less antibody that you're applying to
the western blot
and the reason why we recommend
going with higher antibody dilutions at
least to start off with is we have seen
that some of these ecl substrates if
you're using a very high sensitivity ecl
substrate such as super signal west ato
it can it can blow out your block
because it is so powerful
uh you'll get so much signal that you
won't be able to distinguish
two adjacent bands and so backing off on
that on that antibody concentration is
one way to ensure good results the first
time
now
if you back off on your antibody
concentration and you're not seeing
signal then you can uh optimize your
block by increasing that antibody
concentration again
but you should never go from a low
performing or an entry level ecl
substrate straight to the high
sensitivity substrates
because you will see a lot of signal
because they are very powerful
substrates
all right great thank you caleb got a
couple more questions here
i notice you did not mention super
signal west femto when you talked about
high sensitivity substrates will you be
discontinuing that product
no if you are a super signal west fento
user um
you'll be happy to hear that we do not
plan to discontinue that product
we have introduced super signal west ato
which does provide
better sensitivity
so you can get even more detection of
low abundant proteins however super
signal west femto is also a very
sensitive substrate so if that is
working for your system feel free to
continue using it we do not plan to
discontinue
great thank you caleb our last question
we've got time for one more
does the choice of membrane influence
background and chemiluminescence
detection
um
so the the choice of membrane does not
have as much of an impact in
chemiluminescent detection as as it does
in fluorescence detection
um fluorescence detection as we showed
previously
you can get a lot of background
depending on the
the
wavelength that you are detecting
but we don't see the same type of
contribution to background from a
specific type of membrane
in chemiluminescent detection
thank you caleb
do you have any final comments for our
audience
um just that i really appreciate your
attendance um i'm happy to
have presented and answered your
questions a very engaged audience so
thank you for your attention
and
have a good rest your day good luck with
your western bots
thank you again caleb for your time
today we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor thermo fisher
scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time
goodbye